welcome back Sarah
[Music]
all right what happened to who to whom
and your goddamn father sorry my face is
tired from dealing with everything and
right now I just want to know what
happened with Alec you're not the only
one Suvi I have those senseless thoughts
all the damn time and did he bother you
it's natural you'd have to be made of
stone not to miss home sometimes the
universe is like a giant tapestry I love
following its threads but it distracts
me from the whole picture my family was
right there I was too occupied by the
abstract to appreciate them you're a
pioneer in a new galaxy your family
understood that and they were proud of
you your work as a scientist will help
thousands of people that's real it was a
dream for all of us they always
encouraged me I will do all I can to
make sure my work honors them thank you
writer
where's the Pathfinder you're looking at
her
you're not Alec Ryder my father's dead
he made me his successor Alec is dead
please understand the entire initiative
is at risk you called my father Alec
no one does that a lot of us joined the
initiative because of his vision what he
heard of it anyway were you friends or
I'm not your new mother if that's what
you're asking or his friend he hated
that I didn't use his title but no one's
a pathfinder until they've paths found
something much like a colonial director
without colonies growing up with dad was
tough he and I never really hit it off
but I know he could be distant but he
once said that when his time came he
wanted to go out among stars no one had
seen before
what are we doing in Sam node Sam is now
part of you in a way we don't entirely
understand it played havoc with your
brain Sam
your father authorized the transfer of
pathway to authority to you
shouldn't that be Korah in theory in
reality you're the new Pathfinder Zahra
you